-Welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Thank you for being here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for watching.
Well, guys, as the
war in Ukraine continues,
a lot more American companies
are distancing themselves
from Russia.
And I mean a lot more.
I mean, one of the
major companies is Starbucks.
They just closed all 130
of their stores over there.
Yeah.
And that was just on one street.
-Wow.
-There's always Dunkin' Donuts,
but Putin was like, "Nyet.
That's what America runs on."
And the company that owns
Pizza Hut, KFC, and Taco Bell
suspended its operations
in Russia.
I had no idea Taco Bell
was popular in Russia.
I guess that explains
why everyone sits
50 feet apart from each other.
How good can
Taco Bell be over there?
It's an American company
making Mexican food in Russia.
You know?
It's like a photo copy of
a photo copy of a photo copy.
And then,
facing growing public pressure,
Papa John's announced that it is
halting all
Russian business operations.
Russians were like,
"Finally, some good news."
But it's not just restaurants.
Philip Morris, the maker of
Marlboro cigarettes,
just announced plans
to scale down operations.
That's tough, because in Russia,
cigarettes make up
90% of the food pyramid.
-Potato on top.
-You know you messed up when
even tobacco companies are like,
"We can't be
associated with you.
I'm sorry."
Well, guys, today,
President Biden signed
an executive order to establish
the first-ever strategy
from the federal government
to regulate cryptocurrencies.
I'm just worried now that
the government is involved,
it'll feel like your
parents joining Facebook.
All of a sudden,
it's not cool anymore, yeah.
Biden wants to regulate crypto.
He's even looking into
creating a digital dollar.
It'll look exactly like the
regular dollar bill,
except George Washington will
be replaced with an ape
with sunglasses.
Meanwhile, President Biden
met with business leaders today
to discuss a microchip shortage.
It's kind of
a complicated subject,
but Biden basically wants
to invest billions of dollars
in silicon chip production
to make sure America
is leading in the tech sector.
It makes sense
when you think about it.
I mean...
[ Thinking ] Oh, God,
I should not be talking about
chip production right now.
What the heck
do I know about chips?
Uh, they're in
phones, computers.
Maybe Tariq can hop on this.
I got to bail.
But that's just my take.
I mean, Tariq,
what do you think?
-Oh, well, when you take
a look at the issue of, say,
technological sovereignty,
that we're clearly --
I mean, we're heading to
a dip in the chips --
[ Thinking ] A dip in the chips?
What the hell
am I talking about?
Jimmy told me we were just
going to play charades today.
I'm not qualified
to talk about this.
Oh, I know.
I'll pass it to Higgins.
He reads up on this stuff.
It's actually all theoretical.
Yo, Higgins, did you have
any thoughts on microchips?
-Well, you know, on the
one hand, you obviously have to
account for the differences...
[ Thinking ] Aw, crap!
I thought they were
talking about potato chips
this whole time.
Hmm. I don't do Ruffles because
they hurt the roof of my mouth,
but they are
the best for dipping.
Oh, I can't make up my mind!
-[ Thinking ] What I do is,
I dip one end of the chip
in one dip and one end
in another dip.
Double dip, same chip.
-[ Thinking ] Me? But I don't
know if I even want dip.
Straight chip, no dip, baby.
-And that's why I like to say,
"Straight dip, no chip."
Mmm!
-Ew! -- Hig-- Oh, thank you.
Ugh!
Alright, that's good.
Stop, stop, stop, stop.
-Mmm!
-Thank you. Thank you, Higgins.
We got to the bottom of that.
-So warm.
-Appreciate it. Thank you.
Guys, get this.
I read that Tinder
is now offering
criminal background checks
on potential dates.
Users heard
and were like, "Wait.
You weren't already doing that?
What's going on?"
So now you get
a message that says,
"You've matched with John,
who's wanted in 46 states."
You go, "Cool. People like him."
And, finally,
did you guys see this?
Florida was hit with
some major rain this week,
and it made Disney World flood.
Take a look at this.
Yeah. Right away,
Disney sprang into action
by charging guests
50 bucks for a poncho.
It's like a dry-cleaning bag
with Mickey's head on it, yeah.
Disney tried
to play it off like,
"This is just our
newest attraction --
"Formerly Frozen."
We have a great show.